Hello,
freak bitches.
What's the turtle thing?
What's,
that's a,
a jocular expression I guess
from a Stephen Hawking book.
Um,
it's,
it's a,
it's like an old comedic reference to the
infinite regress problem in cosmology,
which,
you know,
the
based on all the shit we were talking
about earlier and there's a story,
I guess there was some professor at Oxford
or somewhere were given a speech and
explaining how the universe works and,
and everything else in some
little lady stood up and said,
you know,
it's really clever.
I know you think you're
smart but you're wrong.
And he's like,
oh yeah,
well what's,
what's the,
what's the truth?
And she's like,
well,
the earth sits on the back of this giant
cosmic turtle and carries it through
space.
And he said,
well,
what's carrying the turtle?
And she's like,
oh,
that's very clever,
but it's another turtle.
And he's like,
well,
what's under that?
She's like,
you might as well you're
wasting your time.
It's turtles all the way down.
And so hocking referenced
this in brief history of time.
And it's weird because you can look back,
I'm Hindu cosmology and a lot of,
uh,
some native American tribes,
they all held these earthly turtles and
high reverence and the symbology of it
all and they find that story in
different cultures throughout,
you know,
space but thousands of years.
But there's this weird weird referenced
to this cosmic turtle and the Indians or
the Hindu thought there were these four
elephant standing on the back of the
turtle and the earth was a flat disk
rest on its back and it just cruised
through space.
There's a lot of artwork you
can find associated to this.
And I just thought that
it was really the law,
the record at its core is about love.
You know,
being like this one universal truth
and you get a lot of people look to
religion.
A lot of people look to drugs.
I'm not saying you can't get
really spiritual experiences
from all those things,
but I think love at the end of the day
is the one thing that really I've ever
found forced me to want to wake up and
really try to be a better human being.
Every day,
you know,
so that was the main point of the album
and the turtles thing was just kind of,
it's,
it's a way of saying if you get into an
argument with somebody and you realize
it's just pointless,
you're going back and forth.
It's turtles all the way down
because nobody really knows shit,
you know,
and we're all just trying
to not kill each other.
So I don't know.
I decided it would make
a good country song.
Maybe you just need to
talk to Kirk Cameron.
You know,
you're talking a lot of shit,
but you don't really know until
you sit down with Kirk Cameron.
Have you ever seen his buddy that shows
that banana is proof of evolution?
That was the ray comfort.
Yes.
This dumb fuck.
Who doesn't even understand
that we changed the way
bananas look like this guy.
He caused the banana and
the atheist nightmare.
Have you seen that video?
It's beautiful,
man.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
That video's beautiful.
Yeah,
it's and him and Duane Gish and the gish
gallop where you're just like throwing
a word salad at somebody.
It's like,
oh,
well,
evolution isn't true because it's like,
dude,
shut up.
They're all just gay.
That's what it is.
That's fine.
No,
it's great.
Nothing wrong with being gay,
but I really believe that that's what's
going on with most of those guys.
They're the reason why they're so hog.
Wild for Jesus.
Like Kirk Cameron.
That's a gay man.
I'm not a gay man,
but I'm pretty good at spotting
some things in this life.
I know what a gay man it looks like.
I know know it all.
Gay Men look like I've been fooled before,
but you know what I'm saying?
It's like you put a fucking
lizard outfit on dog.
I'm going to go,
hmm.
Something's up with that lizard.
What is this?
That same with the banana.
Oh yeah,
that's.
There it is.
Yeah.
Peeling it and.
Oh Wow.
Man.
Goof bag.
He doesn't eat,
but he never even bothered doing
the work to understand that.
We used to have different looking
fucking bananas within the,
within the written human record
like that ain't that long ago.
Stupid.
Yeah,
it's and,
and somebody brought,
I think once somebody
brought him an actual,
a non,
like an original natural
banana and he was like,
what's that?
It's a banana.
You dumb.
Fuck,
sorry.
Because he started,
he knew that part of his brain is
all just for fighting off cock,
fighting off the love of the COC.
So he puts that just,
I don't have any room for that.
I can't do that kind of research
and busy fighting off the gay.
So I'll just sit here with this banana.
It's pontificate.
I mean he could,
if that,
if as any way shape or form
a hypothesis were true,
it's my thesis.
Why?
Why are you such a phallic symbol?
Why did he,
for all the same reasons,
he doesn't understand what he's doing,
what's drawn to it,
the transference,
you know,
in,
into the symbol.
So it's actually giving them power.
It makes them feel comfortable,
but it's such a ridiculous proposition
that God made a food that we could hold
perfectly well.
What?
Tomatoes are no good,
like why,
why can't you.
I mean a fucking tomatoes
pretty easily held to like,
that's really stupid.
Why isn't banana shaped which tomato?
That's true,
right?
Yeah.
You've got cherry tomatoes carries,
hothouse.
Great.
You know,
all these different ones because we've
modified them and we modified them.
We got involved.
Your light is.
Do you find it really rewarding to be
out in this incredibly wild environment?
Like when you come to a city like
you go from that to New York City.
Is New York City just like a cool little
vacation for you and then do you do,
do you appreciate the wild or do you
appreciate New York because of the wild or
both?
Does that make sense?
You know,
my lifestyle,
the challenges I face and overcoming that,
um,
there is such pride in yourself that,
oh my gosh,
I did that.
How cool is that
in being really little.
I mean,
I,
I terrified of the dark,
but now I live in a place that's
dark for nine months out of the year.
You know,
I mean there are always challenges.
Know yourself better yourself,
you know?
Um,
when I go to a city
a bear,
I know exactly what he wants from me,
you know,
pretty much he's either going to eat you
or he wants something here I was just
passing through,
but it's a pretty honest relationship.
He wants to eat me.
I don't want them to.
You go to a big city and I'm
used to seeing my horizon.
I'm always checking things.
There's no trees,
there's no buildings.
There's nothing tomorrow.
My horizon,
I go to New York and you can't go eight
feet and you've got a 60 story building.
How the hell do you check your horizon?
How do you know what's coming at you?
You see people,
but you cannot be guaranteed.
When I see a bear and he's charging,
I know he wants to attack me.
You see a person walking down the street,
you don't know whether he's going
to pull a gun out of his pocket.
Shake your hand,
pinch your ass or wave goodbye.
You don't know.
So that's a Predator that I'm pretty
impressed people want to be around.
When I got here,
look at all these lights
and all these people.
I'm like,
oh my God,
and they're here on purpose.
What's weird?
And so I always wrestling with this
whole time because when I go to these
places,
I love the culture.
I love the people.
Um,
even there I was trying to
learn Swahili with some of the,
um,
the trackers that we're working with me.
Uh,
Rashidi awesome guy speaks only swahili
but so I really invest myself into the
culture and I just want to learn.
I want to sort of get,
I want to see things through their eyes.
Well,
I saw these grass shacks
and all these people in,
you know,
every grass shack had six
little kids running around it.
And it was just like,
I'm thinking this is awful.
I mean,
it's no hope for six kids at
every grass shack that seems.
I don't know,
it just seemed very sad to me,
but we're,
we're there getting ready to cross this
river in the truck and the river was
high.
So we're kind of out a Ryan Shalom is the,
he's,
he owns Greenleaf,
Tanzania.
And so we're,
we're there and we're kind
of seeing what's going on.
And there was a village about
a quarter mile away and uh,
as we're looking at the river
and trying to make a game plan,
there was music and just
people singing and I'm like,
is it happy hour over here?
What is going on?
And it just,
that really just hit home.
It's like,
you know,
I see him and I think there's no
hope and they must be miserable.
But they're laughing
and singing and dancing
maybe.
Maybe they're okay.
I don't know.
I mean,
are they happy?
They seemed happy to me
so I don't really care.
So it's weird.
It's,
you know,
I don't know.
I can,
I can look at it from
outside and judge and say,
Oh,
you must be so depressed.
Maybe they're not.
I don't know.